hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
gonna answer question from Fatima who's
one of my facebook readers who wrote in
about how to start a new business that
doesn't require money so specifically
the question was I'm a third year
student in accounting and you want to be
an entrepreneur after I finished my
course my question is what business
should I do especially since I don't
have capital right now
Thank You Fatima so thanks for the
question I think it's a great question
one that a lot of people are thinking
about how do I start a business not a
lot of money the key here is you don't
need a lot of money to start almost any
business there are very few businesses
where you absolutely need to have a ton
of money to get started and so what I
would encourage you to do is instead of
trying to find an opportunity where you
don't need a lot of money look at
something where you feel that you can
add a lot of value to and that you're
really passionate about that's gonna be
the key you look at any famous
entrepreneur how they got started and
you ask them what the key to success was
almost always one of the key reasons to
come back is that they had a strong
passion for that business it wasn't just
to make money they wanted to change the
way things were done in a certain
industry you wanted to add a lot of
value to people's lives so don't just go
out looking for the opportunity to make
money you'll often find that the the
people who just try to make money really
do and it's because they quit at the
first sign of trouble they don't put in
the hard work to get past the hurdles I
come in front of them and it's only
because you love your business so much
and you love what you're doing and you
look how much you're helping people
that's what gives you the fuel to keep
going even when times get tough a lot of
entrepreneurs say that they would do
what they were doing for their business
even if they weren't making any money
because of how good it makes them feel
but the value that you they're adding
and they would go and get a job to
support this passion are there so that's
what you want to try to find you want to
find what you love so much that you're
really helping other people and you
would do even if you're not getting paid
to do it because you really love what
you're doing for me I love helping
entrepreneurs I love making these videos
I love
talking entrepreneurs I do a lot of this
stuff without getting paid I'm making
this video for you because I'm not I'm
not getting paid to do it unless there's
some secret person paying me that I'm
not quite sure about but really I don't
make a lot I don't make money from from
these videos but I do it because I love
doing it I love helping entrepreneurs
hopefully you can take this advice go
away put it into your business and
become successful so that's what you
want to find with your own
entrepreneurship venture something that
you're really passionate about will you
wake up excited to do it and you're you
know you're adding a lot of value to
people's lives and that's gonna be the
key is helping other people from there
if you're looking at ways to not spend a
lot of money and that's he you find a
lot of the successful companies started
just from bootstrapping
start a service so service companies are
easier to startup they don't fail as
often as product companies and retail
companies the idea here is you not
spending a lot of money to get started
but you're spending a lot of sweat
equity to put in your time in to see if
it'll work the challenge that people
face on the product side is you spend a
lot of time creating this product you
spend a lot of money buying this product
making purchases and you have a huge
inventory and then doesn't sell and
you've invested all this money into this
product that then sitting in your
basement or your you know extra room or
whatever it is and you can't sell it and
so you're out of pack you have to go
back and get another job or if you're
doing a service it brings you closer to
your customer you really understand what
their pain points are and how you can
help them and then you're not spending a
lot of money you don't really need to
spend any money to start a service-based
business you know you can protection of
a business card maybe a website if you
want but you don't need to spend money
it's more your time as you're able to
build it up and you work with a couple
clients and you know you might be tired
of treating your time for money then you
can't expand into a product type of
business but you have some cash flow
built in from your service so definitely
look at whatever field you're really
passionate about you feel like you got a
lot of value to your clients start a
service around that the third key point
that I want to leave you with is try not
to spend money until you're making money
anybody can spend money it's easy to
spend money if I give you a million
dollars you can go and spend it a
million different ways I'm sure you
could and this is a challenge I had when
I was in the venture capital business we
saw so many entrepreneurs come to us
looking to spend money what you want to
be is that entrepreneur who can earn the
money and so try not to go out and make
a lot of purchases and spend any money
on your business until you're making
something back and this is something
I've tried to apply to all of my new
ideas with my company every new thing
that we try out I'll spend some time and
energy putting it into a see if it'll
work but I won't spend any money on it
until I'm making some money from it
exactly just a couple times with these
videos it's a good example because
you're watching this video so it's a
good medium when I first started doing
video I really wanted to get in a video
because I found that was really a visual
learner and I learned a lot more from
video than just hearing something or
reading something so I wanted to get in
the video but I didn't have a revenue
model behind it so I didn't want to go
and spend money on you know camera
lighting tripod all the things that you
need to make video work I didn't want to
spend money on it because I didn't know
AI would commit to this and continue
doing this if I would like it or not you
don't know if you're gonna like a
project until you actually give in to it
and I didn't know if I'd ever be able to
make money from it so the quickest way
to do it is just start trying it out I
took my regular camera
and just started recording myself and
it's just some questions that people had
written into me and I really did like it
and if you go back to my YouTube channel
and look at the earlier videos they were
really bad the the the quality of the
content was pretty good but the lighting
was bad the camera was bad the audio is
bad because it didn't spend money on a
microphone so that's how we kind of
started off but I've continued with it I
realized I really enjoyed doing it and
eventually was able to find a way to
monetize the video is not all the videos
but some of them through corporate
sponsorships I know you know the money
from those ones help me create all the
other ones so I can spend the time I
want doing these types of videos even
though I'm not getting paid to do it
because it's fun but it gave me the
ability to go and buy a camera and buy
tripod
microphone get some lighting hire an
editor create an intro have some music
on it just to improve the experience and
make the videos that much better so it
all started from nothing like it could
have gone nowhere could have spent all
this money on this gear and I did two
videos and shut the whole project down
and now I'm stuck with all this extra
gear that I'm never gonna use again so
try not to spend money until you're
making money there's a kind of a long
story they kind of get back to that
point whatever business you're going
into if you're passionate about it and
you're creating it around the service
you don't need to spend money you can
find ways to be able to get some
contracts without spending money and
then even though they may not be big
contracts if you can prove to yourself
that hey I'm able to make a little bit
of money here and you really enjoy doing
this this is definitely what you want to
keep doing then you can invest some of
the money that you make back into the
things that will help you grow the
business bigger and bigger bigger and
continue expand from there so maybe that
helped
maybe not the specific answer you were
looking for people sometimes want to
kind of bullet shot here's the exact way
to go about and do it in the type of
business you want to run without any
money but the good news is you can do it
around anything and the more you can
build a business around your passion the
more money you're gonna make and the
more fun you're gonna have to and that's
part of it you're gonna put in a lot of
hours running a business you might as
well be doing something that you really
enjoy and that you know you're helping a
lot of people out instead of just trying
to make some money off of it so
hopefully that helped that if you guys
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below it really makes you want to do
more these videos for you guys and if
you have a comment about this video or
if you have a question for your own
company feel free to leave it in the
comment section below I always read
those to try to respond to everybody as
much as I can so thank you
and I'll see you in the next episode
you